CSS allows us to scope styles to
particular conditions for example
consider the file we have in front of us
the body rule applies in all conditions
however when the device is in landscape
mode we apply a special rule to float
the menu on the right
similarly if someone decides to print
the page we resize the text to use a
smaller font size
yeah media queries are important for a
responsive web design but how does this
help us optimize a critical rendering
path great question first of all check
out the link in the instructor notes to
learn about media queries the web
fundamentals slide has a great and
detailed explanation of how they work
and to answer your actual question let's
say I'm rendering a page that's using
the CSS file we know that the browser
would block rendering until it parses
all of these styles but intuitively do
you think it should block rendering on
the print rules hmm well I guess if
we're not printing the page then there's
really no reason to block rendering
right exactly this is why it makes sense
to sometimes split the CSS into multiple
files let's give this a try our first
step is to move our print styles into a
separate file let's call it style print
CSS next we add an extra link to our
HTML markup and here's the important
part by default the browser assumes that
each specified stylesheet is render
blocking however we can also tell the
browser when the stylesheet should be
applied by adding a media attribute with
the media cleared in this case since
style print CSS is only used for print
we add media print oh so now when the
browser sees a style sheet it knows that
it only needs to apply it for printing
and hence it doesn't need to block
rendering when we're loading on the
phone you got it the browser still
downloads both style sheets but it
wouldn't block rendering on style print
CSS and in this particular case it just
means that the browser has to download
less data for style CSS which would help
with the download speed that makes sense
but this is a pretty trivial example
let's say I've got a much more
complicated set of styles with multiple
breakpoints with this technique help
here as well absolutely you can specify
any media query on the link attribute
and the browser will do the right thing
once again check out the article in the
instructor notes for directions on how
to use media queries
okay now the page speed recommendation
about reducing the number of critical
CSS files makes a lot more sense
glads here let's do a quick quiz to test
your understanding